[Music]
oh
i'll just stick with pewds to be
respectful i like
all right so which one is this one
purple is dead
why is no oh why is no one calling
no jack i just found his body too so
where was it
it's my tree it's on the left side of
the map we all checked vitals
i was next to uh a gamer
one was it was you could see oh yeah
yeah
yeah why do you not i'm so confused
you saw that he was dead like ages ago
yeah yeah i did
oh okay i wanted to find the body yeah
sometimes it's helpful to find the body
so we
oh yeah but where was it charlie found a
tree um
toast where were you so i went to the
lab right away by myself i
did telescope and i started the dropper
and then i went to specimen to do the
sorting and at any point if someone was
on the right side they could deny that
but no one was ever on the right side it
was just by myself
why did you say
did you guys see him i i did the degree
thing i didn't see him
oh but i i went straight there earlier i
checked the telescope and then i went
down and i was
in the room when uh the body was found
or the alert was called
guys this is too slow we need to speed
run come on
who do you want to kill who do you want
to kill who was looking at you funny
how did you think the body was old why
do you think it's like it's weird
because we checked
vitals yeah we couldn't report it again
that's a little weird but all right we
have nothing yeah me
gamer and uh corpse yeah
look i haven't been killed first in a
while so i will not be offended
i'm just gonna go to the bottom left by
myself okay so our lights out now can
they not see anything
[Music]
all right you guys know how i said i'm
gonna go bottom left to get killed
yeah okay i think tycoon showed up and
was
waiting for me there ready i was trying
to protect me
[Music]
also i had my watering cans still
now he was looking for him
would have died already also nobody's
dead and you guys know i would never
kill toast first
oh my god you wouldn't be killing
because no one's dead but i didn't kill
anyone yeah no one's dead
you want people to die
but it's wrong it's wrong i'm not it's
not me
[Music]
when no one joined that are you serious
felix no one enjoying that that's
[ __ ] [ __ ]
i think he just wants to make it spicy
you didn't say
rod no i did say i can't speed one
strike doesn't do it
lily please kill someone i can't i can't
do this
ken is always on to me that [ __ ]
[ __ ] i need to kill ken where is he
no that's wrong tosami go in
do you think they'll vote me out if i
blame michael uh and kill toast
oh my god lily have you killed anyone
uh god damn it lily why did you have to
do it in front of me
okay so this is interesting i don't know
where corbyn's body is but i hogged cams
i went
full [ __ ] cameras on this one i saw a
corpse go top right followed by ken
followed by lily i saw ken and lily
leave top right i never saw corpse leave
but i couldn't find his body
here's the crazy thing cycuno was killed
right as this meeting was called yeah
instant like within point two seconds
wait wait wait how do you know that his
body flopped over as the meeting room
happened
so it's toast right you know i was with
toast actually no
yeah i'm with michael on toast right now
by the button and
you toast and michael definitely did not
wait toast you see psycho floppo
yeah i think i think it's a visual thing
because like he was killed mid
button the game thought he was alive i
know that by the time it
oh who is it oh you know all right
it's round one because of the first kill
i bought it last time
come from the left side and the body was
in the she was the only one i saw come
from the left side and now
she is uh wait i'm doing i'm literally
the only one that likes right now yes
was anyone in storage toast i just i'm
doing the lessons no i wasn't going to
start
here were you with lily that whole time
no i wasn't
what happened to a corpse with corpse uh
no
kind of i was leaving when they kind of
ran by corpse went to the right and then
lily went back out to the left and the
lights went out
i'm gonna i'm skipping it for seven
[Laughter]
all right lily do not kill in front of
me please i gotta kill ken
where is he he's trying to do me out
all right so if you can do lights oh my
god lily
yeah lily kill michael there you are
all right alibi i need an alibi there we
go uh
there we go
okay did they see me okay so
i'm just gonna go full here i'm almost
100 sure it's lily i was suspicious in
the first round in the second round
i was hanging out with you guys the
entire time
and i did the lights i don't think you
got wait no
lily you did not do the lines i was at
the lights oh
[Music]
but she she absolutely was the one that
got the corpse kill
what yeah she killed corpse in the top
right ken just must have missed it
oh i didn't do it that was good enough
for me
i would normally go with you but you've
also accused literally every round
and we got nothing out of it you voted
everywhere convinced me
so i hogged those cams in the second
round i think this is the hardest
evidence
corpse ken and lily all went top right
corpse never came out he died in there
yeah that was his tool
wait where absolutely on top right
where ken and lily were seen exiting the
scene of the crime kin is dead which
means it wasn't
kitten so that means so it's your lily
then
makes sense lily defense well i mean
like if three of you voted it's like i'm
out right
i voted every round i thought it was
till's last round okay
i know who it is
no i'm sorry i'm sorry i thought
we skipped then michael it's actually
not me though
it's not me oh my god i've won
[Laughter]
michael let's keep michael alive then
all right let's go for the double voice
oh my god jesus christ
feels good did you simply so my logic
was lily said michael it's not me and i
said okay
she would not lie or would break the
trust of our union as a couple
that's worse than triangle of choice
don't worry it'll never happen again hey
guys look
look what i am let's get all of these
out of the way
uh oh corpse vented corporate
[Music]
can anyone vouch for corpse walking to
cafeteria
you can you were the only one there that
i walked past you came from the bottom
there
yes i walked past you from the top to
the bottom and then walk from the bottom
up i literally walked past you the first
time what did the log say charlie yeah
interesting corpses movement on the logs
was actually pretty fascinating so
corpse did double in the south beast
which is by me so that means he walked
by the sensor twice
i did not see him past that material i
don't care
oh it came from the sound
i did the water can thing okay i walked
with you guys okay
let's let's think about it log on
charlie it's course okay let's go
larry charlie do you see the y in the
middle
where would i vent to the bottom area
from if i was with them at least i'm
anywhere on this map
this means in the middle of the y in the
middle
of the cafe i can't believe
god everyone's sipping for corpse dude
[Music]
i think jack is checking me out i only
have reactor area left
oh perfect perfect everyone's gonna be
here
i don't have time
i hate this simon says
if you do wrong you gotta go all up
again i'm done with my test
oh [ __ ] corpse if they don't know
it's him now please for the love of god
no you corpse
uh no i shouldn't have gone so hard on
him of course he's going to kill me
oh am i lagging out what's happening did
you guys see that did the server go now
wait i can't get my game oh yeah
oh whoa wait that would explain the law
i thought i lost myself
yes yeah
just like last time with lily like she
never vented either but he was right
oh my gosh it's not about the facts it's
about the gut
uh i i picked the wrong skin can we go
back oh no
no oh can you bamboozle me man i respect
it
whoever's the killer is going to kill me
now no
just don't kill me running right please
i keep thinking i'd die
we did it was dead in front of the
doorway that leads up to reactor like
the very bottom of the
airplane it's not yeah it's a red light
blue
orange or me yeah yeah i
i y'all saw me do the scan right yeah i
had to wait on you who's up at lights
with me
i'm up there i'm doing uh oh yeah
charlie walked in that leaves lily and
gamer
i'm in a cappy lily again isn't it oh my
god no no no this time i'm serious
it
but no one is here with me i literally
just wrapped up
when the lights went out and i'm like to
the admin room now i was a little late i
was following you guys
lily if it's either me or michael it has
to be michael no
there must be someone else because i'm
alone just be in a good way
speed running games voices
hopefully you wait each other's voices
come on yeah literally i can't tell what
lily's
it doesn't sound right i don't know lily
is he lying is he lying or lily is
michael lying or
michael michael are you imposter
no try yes am i lying that sounded
in the doorway that leads to where he is
[Music]
yeah it's michael it's
yeah i'm pretty sure we are i think
everybody's like
didn't work with speedrunning
yeah she was confirmed safe it's a good
amount of tasks
oh perfect perfect perfect yes all right
i'm safe i'm gonna
not die guys i'm gonna live i just gotta
do these ones and i'm done
just don't die in here just get a knock
and die in here come on come on yes yes
i'm done i'm done give me the [ __ ] out
of here
i'm alive i'm alive i'm alive i'm gonna
win i'm gonna win i'm gonna win crew
game it's gonna finish
uh whatever this is oh i'm done i'm done
i'm gonna uh
did anyone see anyone around med bay
i was with a group the entire time i
should have checked the logs
you can still check them if no one
passes and what
log okay okay no wait where was the
buddy it was
uh lice was upset i don't see but chad
is telling me to log [ __ ]
reading chat oh well they i just glanced
come on
wait a minute wait a minute only
imposters can reach chat
chat wait where is
[Music]
oh my god okay um so toast lily and
valkyrie with me coming down from
decontamination
okay okay i'm sorry for mimi all right
should we do is michael or not lily
no valk knows the logs you can check the
logs right
all right what are you doing what do you
need to do well i haven't i haven't done
them yet
like i know how the logs work everybody
everybody's standing still i'm so
confused
i go check with logs everyone's standing
still cafeteria i still hate what you
know him
because only impossible sure that's fair
actually okay
all right don't move and if you move we
vote you out all right
okay yeah okay sure but what if they
call reactor
they have to move well then oh no
okay all right so what should the logs
say then
you'll never understand these logs felix
just a log security packer purify
spedicid pass
north sensor software license
oh gamer or speed ic right
is that reactor it's jack
come on guys all right okay report
report report
okay all right what do you got for us
all right what did the logs say
i got the locks i got the locks all
right i got a screenshot holy sh
all right i scream shut the locks all
right we got it
pewdiepie pasta center and then right
after
right after that right after speed i see
past southwest sensor okay okay
i was literally with everyone the entire
time someone vented right after the call
though
the doors opened and and then they
didn't open again and gnome was in the
south in the balcony
and then felix shows up in reactor
before all of us yeah
but the lines swing reactors
how did you get to reactor so quick wait
what what you were in reaction you said
you were doing real
logs but you were in reactor when you i
checked the oh it's so you dude
you're literally the last one after me
and i'll tell you how i got to the
reactor
i walked there it's not far from logs i
took a screenshot
i mean last one after you oh it's so you
did oh
when we all walked to the left the logs
don't lie
i can screen i can send it in the chat
you know i send the logs in the chat
i don't give a [ __ ] there's the logs
there's the [ __ ] line
i don't care
i can't read this i need charlie
there's another one no
that's impossible oh god the reactor
oh thank god if jack is dead and my mind
will
oh jack zillow wait so it's michael no i
report i found the body
you self-report it no no no no no there
was it was in the y hallway there was
someone else there
yeah that's why i'm at the bottom
okay so there i followed my way to the
bottom i saw someone on the left y of
the hallway
yeah full disclosure well oh is that you
yes
i'm confused as to how you got a report
button and i didn't it was uh he was up
in the hallway yeah i never i think i
can vouch for lily here she was with me
we can solve this no no no we can we can
figure out the last person
let's just check the logs guys
check the logs let's check the lines
everyone wait in cafeteria
we could totally vote here because we
have one wait wait michael where did you
come from the right
side from the little cafeteria area
i think it's i think it's michael but i
think it's not you know what
i'm going to do is
wait corpse was there with me oh my god
okay literally without an alibi
we'll go with corpse next no no no let's
get let's get let's skip and check the
logs
i think we vote michael and then we vote
lily because those are the two
whatever i don't know that's it totally
i'm like 99
i think lilly michael if it's not you
i'm really sorry lily is definitely
innocent
of course and this is why you don't vote
on seven
and this is also why you don't vote on
full i'm done
michael just got played by literally i
[ __ ] called him
so early the last michael's last
charlie to read the box
[Music]
i gotta go guys i'm sorry it's been
great playing with you really fun
i'm sorry for throwing in that last game
all right guys uh thanks for watching
become a member and you can watch these
uh all of them and a ton of other
content offline and it all goes to
charity so
it's a great cause and a great service
and everyone loves it you can join the
discord
do it now members right there i want to
see them pop
up come on guys let's get it until next
[Music]
time